nevermind nope not not gonna do it but a
lot has happened since we last podcasted
bro yeah I know yeah what's happened
well I do believe that 11 and the
stranger things gang finally got Epstein
finally got him they got him in his cell
was it 11 yeah it was 11 yeah everybody
thinks the guards were paid off 11
actually got in there yeah strangled him
via the force okay yeah she had a bloody
nose yeah
Dustin got her out of there Dustin and
Mike are those you know I was like I
haven't watched stranger things at all
but I've been watching like I've seen
some promo clips you know how they're
doing like a giant press run there on
every [ __ ] media outlet every yeah
they look so different the kids it's
really funny on camera yeah they look
mad older they're so old now what the
[ __ ] happened there in the awkward like
teenager phase a lanky and
strange-looking yes some of them just
growing way too fast they look like they
look like adults with wigs playing the
kid versions of themselves yeah yeah
yeah that's a they finally got him I was
actually talking to my my boy who works
in prisons like how how plausible is it
cuz everyone wants to say oh man it was
he was hit he was it was an inside job
bro they got him it was for sure I mean
yeah he was like yeah it's super
possible yeah it's way possible really
mm-hmm
so why is that is because like from he
was like well he's like it
he's like the suicide part probably
unlikely okay he's like you really have
to like really is the way we wave our
friends put it was like it's like some
Simpson [ __ ] where it's like falling
asleep at the console mm-hmm and like
you know [ __ ] Homer like tiptoes by
the camera it's like it would be that
level of [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
what they were claiming was like fatigue
from the job but my homie does like
18-hour 20-hour shifts all the time just
because I think they would put the two
best guards I mean it's not even that
it's like you have like interval checks
every 15 like my boy is saying if he was
actually suicidal like on records who
sytle he'd be checked every 15 minutes
yeah so it's like you know I don't know
but he would say maybe he's not even
dead dude think about that I don't know
we should have asked for it should ask
11 if he's dead or yeah yeah call her up
he's in Drake or chillin oh [ __ ] man
yeah it like sent me down a rabbit hole
of just like [ __ ]
did you see the [ __ ] that he said his
lawyers talking about now he he was
talking with his lawyers about how they
said he was in like super high spirits
they met like they'd been meeting like
every day for like hours at a time to
talk about the case how he was gonna
like yeah how he's gonna like fight the
charges and stuff like that apparently
it was unlike weirdly positive spirits
about everything uh which I don't know
what the [ __ ] that means I mean all this
other means you're not suicidal or
you're not I mean this it's all hearsay
you know what I'm saying yeah I don't
know what I mean I gave just trusting
some the New York Times or something
dumbest thing I could is all hearsay you
know what I'm saying I'm sorry that was
not it's all hearsay I mean it's like
either capper it's no kids not it's
quatorze not yeah he said he said
Epstein kill himself nice cap near your
cap it's a cat bro stop capping God
capping that dude Jacobs Artorias chill
out Jacob Sartorius just got his [ __ ]
wisdom teeth pulled out somebody asked
him about the Epstein situation see how
he responds yo who did that he did what
yo what he thought one [ __ ] kids bro
bro uh nah you could best cap he [ __ ]
kids that's cap you could [ __ ] this kid
oh nice dude if you're a cute girl not
if you're AB Steen Oh got it
word nice it was saying he would use
that to his advantage oh yeah Jacob
lying yeah true yeah you see you see
that Drake tweet what I mean it it
actually like got resurfaced like a
month ago or something but he was like
if amazing was a young [ __ ] then I'd be
in jail because I'm [ __ ] amazing oh
god yeah and everyone was just kind of
like this in poor taste yeah
let me tweeted it like tweet I saw said
you had ten years to delete this no I
haven't yeah ten years ago my man's
let's taking a pedophile lines
that's a pedo bar right there hello war
I actually came up with a pedal board
and then I was like I shouldn't use that
I'm trying with six teens like Dateline
they don't really use sixteen year olds
they use like 12 years yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm going to jail she's 16
that's cat bro I know pedophile that's
cats cab stop they say I'm a pedophile
broadly caffeine bro they capping they
can your honor that is cap objection
that is cap objection sustained
my my client is only here because these
broke muhfuckas is capital
that's the only reason my client is here
does the defendant look like a pedophile
on god that's cab on get on on gap on
cap that's God on cap that's good yeah
look you know I don't get you're lying
I'm trappin I'm trifling with 16s like
I'm Dateline like Dateline like they is
that Chris Hansen [ __ ] yeah what does it
mean to be trapping with six teens like
like you're trapped in 16 s like like
trap house like here you move like vs.
is the [ __ ] I push like that's my 16
bars yes
16 bar oh man I get it now somebody clip
that now don't please and put it in
front of CODIS next verse
that's actually kind of that be fun it's
kind of funny once in 1606 teen bars and
then I go with a [ __ ] yeah
going in with crazy [ __ ] references -
the [ __ ] hater baited me how you
again I [ __ ] ate a Miss enemy enemy
blemish I feel like whenever you hear
most white rappers rap and you could you
could hear their smile like you could
hear their left corner of their mouth
while they're rapping yeah
how you been go away for baiting me you
know how you been go away Amy are you
gonna go away from Amy what are you
saying dude I've been [ __ ] on girls
and thin I'm in boot straight bibbing
it's Bimini what are you are you even
saying is this like a scratch what do
you do red cut my dicks up kissing on
the big butt of a big [ __ ] ah just the
beats not even on dude what is this an a
cappella nah bro beats on that's cab
you're capping I'm hearing sort of what
start I'm started using that [ __ ] every
time I'm in trouble
every single time what did you did you
leave the dishwasher dirty not s cap
that's cap that's cap
yeah that's cap did you leave the cap
off the soda
no that's cab no cat stop you're capping
a cap in bro I am capping right now cuz
you left the [ __ ] thing off Kevin
stop it well I'm gonna have to someone's
got to do it around here
[Music]